hello
welcome to my talk about weeds in weed
management and hemp
my name is lynn sisnoski and i'm an
assistant professor of weed biology
ecology
and management and specialty crops here
at cornell university
weeds in any cropping system compete
with the crop for water
nutrients and light and that can
directly impact
yield quantity and quality
weeds that become established in crops
can alter the microclimates
around the plants which can then impact
disease development
and weeds can actually serve as
alternate hosts for both pests and
pathogens in car cropping systems
vegetation that isn't controlled can
reduce the final harvestability of the
crop
and the absence of any kind of
vegetation control chemicals
in the hemp crop itself may necessitate
the use of
multiple and integrated practices to
suppress
weeds that become established
with respect to integrated weed
management and hemp
the first step should always be proper
site selection
and that means avoiding fields with
perennials or extremely
high weed densities if you're going to
start clean
make sure to try and stay clean always
manage and harvest your cleanest fields
first
with respect to planting date you might
be able to plant and get ahead of weeds
for example if the field that you're
planting into has a lot
of summer emerging weed species
choose an earlier planting date that
allows your crop to get up and gives it
some kind of competitive advantage
against the vegetation it's going to be
competing with
using a stale seed bed technique where
you stimulate the germination
of weeds and then eliminate emerge
ceilings both
physically and chemically can be a
really useful tool
but understand that not all weeds are
going to respond equally well
species with non-dormant seeds might be
better controlled
under this strategy as opposed to
species with dormant seeds
make sure that you have the best
planting conditions that you can achieve
for instance making sure you have a nice
even seed bed
so that you have good soil to seed
contact for even germination
which will improve the crops competitive
ability
make sure that you plant with
appropriate densities to minimize that
open space that weeds can then colonize
if you're using transplants this can be
a really useful strategy to give your
crop a competitive size advantage over
the weeds
choosing varieties can have an influence
on how competitive the crop
is as well based on the heights and the
branching traits that that
varieties possesses if you're going to
be cultivating make sure you keep your
rows as straight as possible
to maximize cultivation performance
and get the weeds while they are small
either at the white thread
or the early seedling stages
if you're using plastic mulch remember
that this is still going to require
weeding between beds
and removing weeds that emerge through
the planting holes
so even though herbicides aren't
available for use in hemp directly
they're likely to be used in crops that
are planted before him
and we have to pay attention to this
because these products have rotation
restrictions on the label
and hemp may not be explicitly listed
but the term other crop often is
and hemp is going to fall into that
other crop
category so if you're interested in
understanding the type of plant back
restrictions that
might be encountered in industrial hemp
production i suggest doing a google
search for the terms wisconsin
hemp and rotation restrictions and
you're really likely to find
this nice handout that was produced by
uw madison
which explicitly looks at the
restrictions
that are associated with the herbicides
that are used in
pre-seeding crops
these are some of the rotation
restrictions that my colleagues at uw
madison
found across multiple herbicide labels
and you can see they're extremely
varied in the amount of time that you
need to wait before you can plant
industrial hemp
for example for the fuselage and select
max labels there was a one-month
rotation restriction
for something like pursuit in the zether
pair
there was a 40-month rotation
restriction
now understand the list is not inclusive
and labels can
and do change and it is your
responsibility to always consult the
labels
before making any herbicide application
and before planting crops
following herbicide applications
just because we don't have herbicides
currently labeled for use in hemp
doesn't mean that we aren't looking to
see how herbicides
affect him we have a lot of herbicide
trials that are currently
underway in the united states and
they're being undertaken
for multiple reasons the first of which
is to identify active ingredients that
will be safe to use
in hemp and to address pest management
needs in the u.s hemp
industry the second reason is to
identify herbicides that will be able to
control
hemp escapes that occur in following
crops
and the third reason is to characterize
herbicide
symptomology in the case of herbicide
carryover or
drift injury
while there's considerable interest in
conducting hemp herbicide trials
very few have actually made it to formal
publications stage yet
the one exception being some work that's
been recently undertaken by michael
flesner's group
at virginia tech university and this is
a really good paper where they evaluated
herbicide tolerance of
industrial hemp in both greenhouse and
field conditions
so the objective of the research that
was conducted in michael flesner's lab
was to test
hep tolerance to both pre-emergence and
post-emergent herbicides
and when we say pre-emergent herbicides
we're talking soil applied herbicides
and when we're talking post-emergence
we're talking fully or applied
herbicides
they did conduct this across years and
they did do the studies in both
greenhouse and in field trials and what
they saw
was variability across time and
between growing conditions
although with respect to the results
they did find that esmetolochlor
was the least injurious of the soil
applied herbicides in the field
although their greenhouse trials did
suggest that other active ingredients
may have potential for future research
with respect to the foliar applied
herbicides
quizalifop and cythoxidim which are both
grass herbicides
were found to be the least injurious of
the post products
along with clopirolid and bromoxinil
i'd like you to know that we're also
conducting herbicide trials
here at cornell agritech these are the
results from
a preliminary screening project that
we've started to look at the
safety of post-emergence or foliar
applied herbicides on industrial hemp
and you can see that our results largely
agree with those that were
achieved by michael flechner's group
primarily if we're looking at percent
injury
the post-emergence herbicides currently
in our trial providing the least amount
of
injury to hemp are clethodyn which is a
wssa1 herbicide
clopyramid and bromoxinil
so we plan to continue these herbicide
screens both in the greenhouse and under
field conditions this fall
and in 2021 the previous slide
showed you our post-emergence herbicides
that we're looking at
we also have a suite of pre-emergence
herbicides that we'll be evaluating
and again we'll be doing it in both the
greenhouse and field conditions
we hope to have some trials describing
the impacts of herbicide carry over and
drift on crop
growth and yield development
we're also hoping to look at the biology
of
hemp and evaluate its competitiveness
with both current weed issues such as
velvetly
foxtail bindweed and nightshade and up
and coming problems in new york such as
palmer amaranth and waterhemp
i'd like to thank you very much for
attending today's talk
if you'd like to get in touch with me to
discuss weeds in weed management
in hemp or in any specialty crops
feel free to contact me via email at
lms438
cornell.edu on my office phone
at 315-787-2231
if you're on social media you can find
me on both twitter
and instagram again thank you so much
for coming and attending my talk
i'll be present during the break if you
have any questions
and have a good rest of your day